well first of all congratulations on
season five i've been all eight episodes
ahead of this interview yesterday and i
think it's the best season yet oh my god
excellent um i'm gonna be asking some
spoilery questions i'm going to hold
them until the episodes so don't feel
bad about talking about any plot points
and i want to start with uh max at the
end of season four we learned that nick
has gotten married and in season five he
gets to see a little bit of his
relationship with his wife
what has it been like for you getting to
explore this new phase of nick's life
and is there a real love there
marriage that's what i'm learning
not a strong point um another
complicated marriage for nick in quick
succession um
i think there's a mutu there's there's
so much in the first interaction you see
between nick and rose and the show
there's so much sort of
off-screen information that we're
getting in terms of
what their dynamic must be how much
they must share between one another and
it's clear i think to me from the outset
that there's real
trust between them
and um
i think that he trusts rose in a way we
haven't really seen him trust anybody
outside of june on the show so it's
obviously a meaningful relationship it
does strike me as
maybe
more strategic
or
um
a marriage of convenience perhaps more
than a romantic i i think the the log
line for this year i don't know uh
really should be that gilead is for
lovers
[Laughter]
you know you say that i'm you know
calling him in here from virginia which
is virginia's for lovers so if that's
the tagline for handmaid's tale it makes
yes it's very similar to virginia
very good
uh bradley so kind of at the beginning
of the season the center point is fred's
funeral and all of this
and commander lawrence is really kind of
championing this for serena when a lot
of the other guys in gilead aren't
really
interested in it what is his endgame
here what is he hoping to achieve by
publicizing fred's funeral uh you know
it's really interesting i i i think um i
think it's another example of of
uh lawrence
uh
being led by by
uh
by the women i i like i i
i think initially he thinks
you know it's it's an absolutely crazy
idea
and then i i i think he thinks serena
has a has a kind of
um
brilliant intuition about
uh an event that that
could end up
um
uh
lifting lawrence and lifting uh
lifting gillian uh but i think there's
an actual moment i think
he's absolutely genuine when he
initially thinks it's a bad idea and
then i i i haven't seen the episode but
uh i think there i was i hope that
there's a sense of him realizing oh wow
yeah that's that's a very interesting
idea and it moves us
for my purposes it moves us
right past uh the uh questions about
fred's murder it moves us
you know just beyond it uh immediately
so i think there's strategic reasons but
i think he's impressed that she comes up
with this
speaking to a friend's murder it's
really interesting like that whole
episode is interesting because obviously
nick knows what happens to fred serena
knows that june knows the serena
probably thinks that nick probably knows
and max i was wondering what is it like
to play with those layers of deception
because everyone is playing a game
everyone has their own kind of
plans that's happening in that episode
um i think it's one of the great joys of
doing this show is the space in between
you know it's it's
um
bradley often said the scripts are lying
you know that people are
are off to say
like
in life people often say the
antithesis of how they actually feel um
so i really and i enjoy i enjoy that
i've always enjoyed that in the show i
think particularly for me this year and
a little bit last year getting to work
more brad
um not lisa admire so much but i think
somebody's brilliant at interrogating
and mining those spaces it makes it all
the more good fun just to add i i think
max is right there is a particular joy
um
uh on this show because of the spaces
uh because of the paranoia um
lizzie and i have talked about it uh the
term that would
the term that we use is sort of swimming
in the weird
of
of um
there's a lot of subtext going on going
off of that and the subjects of all of
that like commander lawrence is
definitely one of the more sane men in
gilead and he has really big plans for
gilead in this season particularly do
you think that paints a target on his
back at all among the other men in
gilead absolutely i yeah i i look i
think that there is
uh i think something
there's an abandon to him in the wake of
the death of of of eleanor that that
continues uh in this
season um and
uh
you know i think that
that um
june has
shown
a
a pretty dark guy
what he thinks
is a a potential path to redemption
uh in some ways i think you'll see it
comes into conflict with
um
with
what june uh thinks can be done and
should be done which i think lawrence
thinks might be a little
uh a little naive uh
uh at this point but yeah i listen i i i
you know i've gone i it's so interesting
i brought this dangerous girl into my
home this notoriously misbehaving
handmaid and then i have gone way out on
a limb whether it's angel's flight or
fred's
uh uh
murder um uh
i i think he's
um
i i i i think he's in a always in a very
dangerous spot
by the way
your palette here is just it's like some
art director who did this
so my last question is for max um it
always feels so weird to say that nick
and june are like one of my favorite
aspects of the show because there is so
much more than that relationship i was
really curious to know how you and
elizabeth keep it grounded keep that
connection and maybe where you see that
relationship going especially now with
these new complications
i don't know where it's going
i really don't we don't know what's
gonna happen on the show so it there is
this kind of much like life this kind of
mystery of what what will come next
um i love working with her i love doing
those scenes it is a thrill um
it's a thrill to get to where somebody's
that good and to
is to play off this kind of very
heightened
um
and i think you know in a show that has
very dense ideas and is very
intellectual and heavy it's kind of fun
to do some stuff that feels
um
what's the word i'm looking for brad
like it's a little bit
heightened it's a little bit more
yeah it's a very it's a very depressed
situation and it's just too bad that you
guys don't have any chemistry i mean
on screen that's
imaginable
lizzie and i were what i saw last night
and we were saying you know we never met
before we did the show
none of us had met before we did the
show she never met ot before she did the
show and it is a miracle that you know
that there is some kind of on-screen
connection it's fantastic because who
knows it could go terribly wrong yes i
as an old man who's done this for a long
time uh uh you know this show is one of
those miracles of alchemy on many
different levels um
and
uh
it's a miracle when it happens
um
you can set out to do it but it can be
very elusive but i do feel like the
chemistry between lawrence and nick may
start rival but
the junior it's pretty intense it's
pretty intense there's a lot of
happiness yes it is
well thank you both so much for taking
the time this morning i'm assuming it's
morning for you as well to chat with
collider thank you thank you maggie
say hi to baby yoda for us oh i shall i
shall i have many